[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW O. JACKSON: So,
why write this book?
There is a lot of
regularity in the way
that people are
organized and how
that influences their outcomes.
And in the book, I
sort of intertwine
two different themes.
One is that our networks
have special features.
And those features are
simple and quantifiable.
And the second is that they
have impacts on our lives.
And the sort of topics
I include and discuss
are things like influence--
how people are influenced.
How do you define
influential people?
And how does it
depend on the context?
What kind of biases
do we have in forming
opinions and beliefs?
Things like contagion and
how financial contagions are
different from a flu
contagion, things
like how splits in our
networks feed polarization,
feed inequality,
freedom mobility--
and then how patterns
are changing over time.
I'll just go through a
few illustrative examples.
And what I want to start with
is just a simple picture.
What I'm going to do is show
you a series of pictures.
The first picture is one
of a fictional high school.
And then I'm going to show
you a real high school.
And what I want to do
is contrast the two.
And then you'll be able to see
the patterns that typically
emerge.
So the high school
I'm going to show you
is one from what's known
as the Add Health data set.
And that data set
looks at high schools,
and how people's
friendships form,
and what patterns they take.
And so what I've
done here is I've
created a fictional
network, which
is exactly the same as
the high school in terms
of the number of students
and a number of friendships.
But I randomly place
the friendships
instead of putting
them in the structure
that they appear
in the high school.
And so I want to do
is just contrast that.
So here, it just sort of
looks like a spaghetti bowl.
There's a bunch of students.
They're connected.
And you don't see any patterns.
And now I'm going to show
you a real high school.
So this is a real high school
from the Add Health data set--
255 students.
And now you'll
notice that there's
some patterns that emerge.
And just in terms of contrast,
here everybody has friends.
So there's no isolated nodes.
When you get to this one,
there are some isolated nodes.
So there's some students who
don't have close friendships.
And these were
defined by people who
did at least three different
activities in a given time
period with each other.
The other thing is that
I had an algorithm that
drew this picture.
So you'll notice
that there's sort
of a split between
the top of the picture
and the bottom of the picture.
The top of the picture, you
have connections in a group.
And the bottom of the picture
has connections in a group.
And there's not many connections
across the two groups.
So there's sort of a
split in this graph.
And the algorithm that
drew this, what it does
is it doesn't know
where to place things.
It just looks, and
it picks two nodes.
And if they're connected, it
pulls them closer together.
If they're not connected, it
pushes them further apart.
And it just does this
until you stop it.
And so it goes.
And it tries to find
the community patterns
in the network.
Now what I'm going to do
is take this and color it.
And what I'm doing now
is coloring it by race.
So the blue nodes
are black students.
The yellow nodes
are white students.
The red nodes are
Hispanic students.
And now you'll begin to notice
that there's strong segregation
patterns in this network.
Basically, there's only, I
think, three strong friendships
between blacks and whites
in the whole high school.
And you'll see that it's
a strongly segregated
across racial lines.
And that's even despite the
fact that this high school
looks well-integrated in
terms of the composition
of the high school.
So you've got a
high school where
you think is well-integrated.
But if you look internally,
it's completely segregated.
Here's another picture.
This is another high school.
But now it's
color-coded by gender.
And the links are actually
romantic or sexual
relationships during an
18-month period of the study.
And here you'll notice,
also, in the 63, and the 2,
and the 12, 9--
those are numbers of how many
times that subgraph appears.
So there is a 63
pairs that didn't
connect with anybody else.
But you'll notice
on the left, there's
a giant component--
what it's called.
So this is a component
where, basically, you
could draw a path from any
node in that to any other node.
So even though each person
has few relationships,
you're able to actually
trace from one to another.
And that means when you're
looking at things like disease
spread and things--
or even rumors spread,
other kinds of things--
understanding this component
structure of the network
can be very important
in understanding
how things spread.
So in going back to
this idea that there's
a difference between these
networks and random networks,
one thing that's
true is you end up
having some nodes that
have very many connections,
and some that have
very few connections,
and essentially what's known as
fat tails in the distribution.
So when you look at the
distribution of friendships,
you see more people who have
very few and more people who
have very many connections
than you would normally
see just at random.
And this has some impact.
And one thing I
want to start with
is just talking about what's
known as the friendship
paradox.
And this is something
that we're all constantly
bombarded by, essentially.
And it's the fact
that our friends
are more popular than we are.
And that sounds like
a strange thing.
How can it be that
your friends are all
much more popular than you are?
On average, people's
friends tend
to be more popular
than they are.
And why is that true?
When you look at
somebody who has,
say, 20 friends and somebody
who has two friends,
the person who has
20 friends is going
to appear in a lot of
people's friendship counts.
So people who have
the most friendships
appear as friends
to the most people.
And so our samples of friends
are not random samples
from the population.
They tend to be heavily
biased towards the people who
are the most popular.
And that ends up
having consequences.
So if these people
act differently
than the rest of the
population, then you
end up having a
distortion in terms
of when you look at
your friends and what
their behaviors look like.
And if you project that to
the rest of the population,
it's not a random sample.
And social media accelerated
this, in fact, or amplified it.
So if you look at, say,
Twitter, typically the follower
has 10 times fewer
followers than the people
that they're following.
So there, it gets
even more extreme.
But to understand the
illustration of this,
if you look in middle school,
each additional friend
that a kid has makes them
6% more likely to have tried
alcohol by the time
they become a teenager
and 5% more likely to
have smoked by the time
they become a teenager.
So basically, the kids
who are the most popular
are ones who tend to be
trying things at earlier ages.
And that also goes--
there's a whole series
of studies on drugs.
And they tend to be
experimenting in earlier ages.
And then the students
who are friends
with them are seeing
their behaviors
and projecting that often to
the rest of the population.
So people systematically
overestimate the amount
of consumption of drugs,
alcohol, smoking that goes on
in a population in
schools, because they're
being overexposed to people who
are following those behaviors.
So that ends up having an impact
in terms of what people see.
There's also something
that's very true
both in social networks that
are purely social-- where you're
just talking about
friends that you're
meeting physically or online.
And that's a rich get
richer phenomenon.
So when you begin to look
at how you find friends,
often you meet people through
people you already know.
If you're in a business,
you meet customers
through your existing customers.
And the fact that
this happens means
that, the more opportunities
you have to meet people,
the easier it is to meet people.
And that snowballs.
And so you see this
acceleration in terms of--
some people end up with
very many connections.
Other people end up with
very few connections.
And that happens through
all sorts of media.
You can look at videos,
whether they go viral or not,
and look at the quality of them.
And there can be very
high-quality ones that
don't and other ones that do.
And that has this kind
of feedback effect.
And so in networks,
you get these kinds
of exacerbated inequality in
terms of social connections.
And those social connections
have consequences.
Now going back to this
other segregation pattern
that we see, let me take you
through a couple of examples
of this.
So this is another example
from a study we did in India.
And now what I've done
is coded things by caste.
So this is an Indian village.
These are connections
between households.
And a connection
between household
is usually that they're
borrowing and lending
money, kerosene, rice.
They're giving each
other medical help.
So this is a poor village.
And they're basically
helping each other out.
And the caste designation
here-- the red nodes
are the relatively
disadvantaged caste.
So these are scheduled
castes and scheduled tribes.
So these are the ones
that are recognized
by the Indian government
for affirmative action.
And the blue squares are the
relatively advantaged castes.
And these villages are
not very advantaged.
But they're considered to be
better off by the government
than then the other ones.
So those are the
otherwise backward castes
and general merit.
And here you can begin to
see that, again, you're
15 times more likely
to be connected
with somebody in your own
caste than across castes.
So these are strong boundaries.
And you can also see,
even among the schedule
castes and scheduled tribes,
there are strong cuts.
And these cut both on religion.
So Muslim and Hindu
don't interact much
in these villages.
And also, for instance, the
Dalit, the untouchable caste,
are often their
own group and don't
communicate with other groups.
And so you can go
into a village.
We were going into
these villages
to try and spread
microfinance information.
And it turns out that, if
you hit one of these groups
and you don't hit
multiple groups,
you basically don't get
the information out.
So it's really important.
They're very insular.
So even if it's a village
of 200 households,
you think everybody
must know each other.
They've lived their whole lives.
200 households-- how can
they not be communicating?
They can really be quite
segregated and quite
introspective,
even though they're
in close proximity and
in this kind of setting
with lots of other individuals
that have differences.
But they just don't
really communicate.
When you get back
to the high school,
you end up having impact on
whether people go to college.
We're doing a study
now where we're
trying to understand
decisions to go to college
and how those peer affected.
And again, you're
mostly influenced
by your close friends.
And even getting
basic information
about how to study for SATs,
or how to apply to colleges,
or what kind of financial
aid is available,
all kinds of things
that seem fairly simple
can be something that's
very alien to certain groups
internally.
And as people grow up, it
gets even more pronounced,
in a sense that, when you
look at access to jobs,
roughly 50% to 70% of
jobs are originally
obtained through referrals,
meaning you know somebody
at the company.
They help get you an interview.
And if you don't
have that interview,
it's very difficult
to get looked at.
And what that does
is it exacerbates
this persistent inequality, in
a sense that, if I'm in a group
that where very few of
my friends are employed
and they have low wages,
it's very difficult for me
to get information about
jobs to get contacts
and to actually get jobs.
And so then I have
more incentives
to drop out of the labor force.
I have less incentives
to invest in education.
And this goes along over time.
There's a really interesting
study by Ron Laschever.
And he was trying-- so this is
very difficult to tease out.
When you're doing
research on this,
it's very difficult
to tell why--
if two people are connected
and neither of them
are getting a job,
it's very difficult
to tell whether there's an
effect from one to the other.
Because it could
be that these are
people who just are unemployed.
And unemployed people tend to
be friends with each other.
And employed people tend to
So what he did is
he took advantage
of a random assignment of
people to friend groups.
And the way he did it was
he looked at the draft
in the First World War.
So in the First World War, the
US Army went from about 300,000
or 400,000 people in 1917
to almost 4 million people
enlisted by 1918.
So it was an enormous growth
in a very short period of time.
And the way they did
this was a random draft.
You got drafted.
And then people were put
into companies of 100 people.
So you were just thrown into
these people with other people.
And it was done
completely randomly just
by the order of your number
that you were drafted in.
And then these people
literally spent
a couple of years in the
trenches with each other.
So they became
very close friends.
And then what he does is
he follows their employment
trajectories after the
war through the 1930s.
And when you look at
somebody in my company,
if there's a 10% increase in the
employment rate in my company,
that corresponded to a 4%
increase in my employment
on average.
So basically, you're getting
about a 40% spillover
of your friends employment
to your own employment
just by completely random
assignment of friends.
So it gives you
an idea that this
can be a powerful force in terms
of whether or not people have
access to jobs.
And it gives you
an idea that, when
you're looking at groups that
are relatively disadvantaged,
it's very difficult
to get out of that.
Because they don't
have the opportunity
to access that other people do.
One of the most, I
think, impressive studies
in quantifying these
effects was what's
known as the Moving
to Opportunity study.
I don't know if
people know that.
So this was a study that was
done by the US government
in the 1990s.
And what they did was they gave
different families vouchers.
They gave them vouchers.
And what was a voucher good for?
The voucher would pay your rent.
So they were giving
low-income families
vouchers to pay for rent.
And they had about 4,500
households-- a little
more than 4,500.
And they broke them
into three groups.
A third of them,
they gave vouchers.
And they could just
paid for their rent.
A third of them, they
gave nothing just
as a control group.
And a third of them, they
gave vouchers but only
if they agreed to move to
a wealthier neighborhood.
So they had to move.
And they had to move to a
neighborhood that was higher
up in the income distribution.
And what they found
was, if your family--
so now you can look back at this
and see what the outcome was.
And a family that moved
with an eight-year-old
child from a poor location
to a wealthier location, now
the eight-year-old child,
in terms of lifetime income,
looks like they're
about $300,000
higher in terms of
lifetime income.
They're 1/6 more likely
to have gone to college.
They're less likely
to be single parents.
to be incarcerated.
They have better
health outcomes.
So essentially, taking
them out of one community,
putting them into another
community made a big difference
in who their peers were,
what the parental peers were,
and then what their life was
like as a result of this.
Now obviously,
social engineering
is not an easy thing to do.
We don't want to start just
going around and trying
to rewire everybody's networks.
But what that does tell us
is that these things can
have a very large impact.
And interestingly,
the impact depended
on how old the kids were.
So an eight-year-old
kid got a huge impact.
An 18-year-old kid
had almost no impact.
So if you took an
18-year-old, they basically
had already had
their social network
and a lot of impact on them.
And it really made
very little difference
in terms of outcomes.
I spend more time in the book
also talking about learning
and how people learn
information through networks.
And I think now, with all
the discussion of fake news,
and polarization,
and echo chambers,
there's a lot we can actually
learn from the basic network
structures in terms of the
kinds of biases that operate.
And there's a
fascinating study that
goes way back, which
is known as Vox Populi.
I don't know if
people know the term.
It's the wisdom of the crowds.
And this was a guy named
Sir Francis Galton.
And he published a paper in the
"Journal of Nature" in 1907.
And what it did was-- he
went to a fair in England.
And it was a fair
where you could
guess the weight of an ox.
So there was an ox there.
The ox weighed 1,198 pounds.
And then for a fee, you could
guess the weight of the ox.
And then whoever got closest to
the actual weight won a prize.
And what he did is he
collected all the guesses.
And there were 787 guesses.
And the average guess in the
population was 1,197 pounds.
So it was 1 pound short of
the actual weight of the ox.
And the median was actually
just over 1,200 pounds.
So basically, the
middle this distribution
was just centered right
on the actual weight.
And then there was
quite a variance on it.
But what that tells you
is that, collectively,
if everybody could
share their information,
often you can come to the
right kind of decision
or the right kind of
knowledge about some facts.
But then we're subject to
all kinds of issues in terms
of the biases that we face.
So as we see in these
kinds of networks,
we're not necessarily
listening to everybody equally.
So if there's biases in terms
of what kinds of information
people have-- depending
on ethnicity, age, gender,
profession, et cetera--
then if we're only
talking to those people,
we don't get nearly
the information
to aggregate up to come to
the wisdom of the crowd.
And so that's a difficult thing.
And also, humans are
very good at counting.
So if you think about
the information you hear.
So suppose there's
a new movie out.
And you hear from
seven of your friends
that this is a movie
you have to go to.
They've just heard
it's really wonderful.
You count that implicitly.
The more people
you hear that from,
the more you begin
to believe it.
But it could be that all those
people read the same review.
So it could be that all of that
is traced back to one source.
And when you're looking at
these kinds of networks,
it's very easy for you to be
being bombarded by information
which is all coming
from the same source
and then repeating it.
And these kinds of echo chambers
do lead to false beliefs
in a variety of settings.
So what I want to
do to just talk
a little bit about the
trends in networks--
and what I'm going to
do here is take you
through a couple of
pictures of how things
have been changing over time.
And it's actually
difficult to find pictures
of networks that go far back.
So what I've done
here is-- this is
from a study I did
with Steven Nigh.
And this goes all the way
back to the Napoleonic Wars.
And now what we're looking at is
connections between countries.
So these are countries.
And a link between
two of them is if they
had a military alliance--
so either a positive
alliance that they
agreed to be allies
in some confrontation,
or they agreed not
to attack each other.
So what we'll start
is just by looking
at these things over time and
seeing how they're changing.
So right after the
Napoleonic Wars,
we had a group that
were connected.
They lasted together
for a while.
You keep going.
Things are bouncing
around a little bit.
1870s were a pretty
rough period.
The unification of Germany
happened just after this--
Otto Von Bismarck
appears in the 1870s.
And then you start
seeing new connections.
You get to just before
the First World War.
1920s were a rough period.
The 1930s, you begin to
see things take place.
And now when you look
post 1950, you'll
see very different
patterns emerging.
So here things are
getting a lot denser.
And by the time you
get to 2000, you
see an incredibly dense network.
And the network now--
you can place your favorite
country in this network.
There's two different features,
before 1950 and after 1950.
Before 1950, people
tended to have
about two and a half
allies-- so many fewer.
And the chance that they lasted
for five years was about 2/3.
So if you look in an alliance,
look five years later,
the chance it survives
was about 2/3.
Now people have about
10 and 1/2 allies.
And the chance that
it lasts is about 95%.
So there's a much higher
chance that it lasts.
And if you begin to
look at this network--
I don't have the pictures
for the trade networks going
over this time period,
but they really
closely overlap with trade.
And so a lot of it
is cemented by trade.
And the globalization
that's been going on
in terms of trade networks,
both directly in terms
of goods and financial networks,
really are what cement these.
And that's why they
don't disappear
and why it's becoming
increasingly dense.
The good news
about this is that,
when you look at the
incidence of wars over time,
basically, once this
network has started
densifying the wars have
pretty much disappeared
by historical standards.
So even though we
still have wars,
most of the big wars
in the past few decades
have actually been in Africa.
But if you look at the history
of what's still going on,
we have about 1/10
the frequency of wars
post-1950 as we had before 1950.
So it's actually a much
more peaceful period
than people realize.
And there's different
ways of measuring it.
This is off of a
data set that we
used which was called the
Correlates of War data set.
But basically, things are
becoming much more peaceful.
And that's really has
an enormous amount
to do with trade.
If you throw nuclear
weapons into the mix,
you really can't explain
the patterns of wars.
The patterns of wars really seem
to be explained by the trade.
And when you look at the same--
this is just world trade
as a percentage of GDP--
it's just been
going up steadily.
So the world trade network
has been growing denser.
That's cementing relationships
and actually leading
to a lot of peace.
And when you look at
the remaining conflicts
in the world--
for instance, if
you look at what's
going on in the
Middle East, Israel
is surrounded by countries
that it doesn't trade with.
So Jordan is the only country
that has any trade with.
And I think Jordan ranks 20th
on its list of trade partners.
When you look at
North Korea, it's
fairly isolated
in terms of trade.
When you look at US
trade with Russia,
it's actually a
relatively low trade
dyad given the size
of the two economies.
So just understanding
that, I think,
gives us a lens into
how these networks
are changing over time.
And it's an important
thing in light of Brexit
and a whole series
of other things.
You don't want to
be too alarmist.
But anything that
moves trade backwards
is moving us in
the wrong direction
in terms of the networks.
What I wanted to
end with is just
a question of whether
the world's actually
becoming more polarized.
And before I show you
the full pictures here,
I want to say a couple
of things about that.
So one is-- and this is
something that people at Google
know well--
is that algorithms are
important in determining
what people have
access to and how
they connect to other people.
And one thing that's
happening over time
is our world's becoming denser
in terms of the connections.
So we can maintain relationships
at a much greater distance.
But we also have
search engines--
the system is so
difficult to navigate
that you need some way of
finding things and finding
people.
And one thing that
allows us to do
is find other
people who actually
have very similar interests
to us, or like things,
and find things
that we can like,
and have the systems
show those to us.
And so that plays off
of this homophily--
the segregation in networks
that is so prevalent.
Our natural tendency
is to look for things
that are similar to ourselves.
It gets amplified by this.
And so there's been
some discussion
about whether the
world's more polarized.
This is a picture
from Senate co-voting.
And here, what each
dot is is a senator.
And this is from
the 1990 Senate.
And this is from code I got
from Renzo Lucioni, who's
a computer scientist.
And all I did was
look at the 1990
Senate, look at all the
votes that happened.
And we'll put two
senators together
if they voted the same way
more than half the time.
So if they agreed more
than they disagreed,
we'll put a link between them.
So it just shows, how
cohesive is the Senate
in terms of co-voting patterns?
Are people agreeing,
not agreeing?
And again, the algorithm doesn't
know the colors of the nodes.
It puts them on the
page by putting people
together that co-vote similarly
and pulling them apart
if they're not.
And so it gives us a picture.
And what you can
see-- this is 2015.
So the question of whether
the voting is becoming more
polarized-- you
can just see the--
I didn't pull this apart.
The algorithm does that.
So now the chance that you
co-vote with somebody-- before,
it was 82%.
So here, 82% of the senators
were linked to each other.
Now it's 53%.
And most of them tend to
be within their own party.
So, very few of the
connections go across parties.
And you can fill in where
your favorite senator is
and so forth.
Interestingly, some of the
Republicans like Rubio,
and Cruz, and Graham end
up at very different points
and very different--
so you can begin
to place people on
a political spectrum
partly by who they're
co-voting with.
But what this does
say is that some of--
the ideas that there's more
tension and less agreement
is partly true.
It's a little difficult
with the Senate stuff,
because what is
actually being voted on
is changing over time, as well.
And so there's other things
going on at the same time.
But you begin to see
that there's definitely
a pattern here.
Other kinds of things--
it took four years
for the plague
to go from Marseille
to Stockholm.
It took a week from Ebola to
get from Africa to New York.
So the world is
becoming more connected.
That's great in a lot of ways.
So the globalization
we showed you
is leading to a lot of peace.
We see people being able
to be connected that they
weren't connecting before.
The world poverty rate has
come down from over 40%
to less than 10% since 1980.
There's all kinds of
great news in terms
of all these connections.
But at the same time,
I think the fact
that we're becoming
more connected-- we
can become more connected
and actually more segregated
at the same time.
And you're seeing both of
those effects happening.
And it's an interesting
time to be studying
networks for that reason.
I think that's a good time to
stop and ask for your questions
and comments.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering for
your better-off/worse-off group
scenario, if we establish enough
connection between the groups
if one group can
simulate the other?
MATTHEW O. JACKSON:
Yeah, I think--
so being aware of the
homophily and the segregation
across groups helps
us understand, look,
there's not necessarily
information and opportunities
flowing to these groups.
Part of the difficulty in
just establishing links
across the groups
is that you need
to put a lot of links in
there if you want to do things
that are peer influenced.
So if you look inside
the high schools--
we've been doing studies
on alcohol consumption,
and drug consumption,
and things.
And if you look at those,
a rough rule of thumb
is that the students
sort of act like
the majority of their friends.
And that means that, if you've
got these segregation patterns,
you'd have to put in an
enormous number of connections
to really correct for the fact
that they're very segmented.
So it's not an easy
thing to overcome.
And I think that some
things that can be done
are mentoring programs,
especially when it gets
to getting people into college.
So if it's hard to build
many relationships,
instead you can build
really strong ones.
So put somebody in who can
actually go into a student--
and instead of just sending
them information, say, OK, look,
here's a mentor.
Here's somebody who
went to college.
They can tell you
about what you need
to do to apply, what your
life is going to be like,
and spend concentrated
time with them.
I think that that's
very important.
AUDIENCE: I just wondering
how the techniques of studying
things like this-- sociological
networks or economics--
has changed with
advances in technology,
and availability of data,
and things like that?
MATTHEW O. JACKSON: Yeah,
that's a great question.
And it's really a fun
time to be doing this.
Because the data are
exploding in terms of--
the number and
richness of data sets
is really extraordinary now.
And there are a
lot more techniques
that we have for working
with large data sets.
So the ones I've shown you are
ones that can be visualized,
which are usually smaller.
But you can handle ones with
hundreds of millions of nodes.
And we're actually doing
that with some various media
platforms in trying
to understand
how people are connecting and
what the implications are.
So large data sets are
becoming available.
And often, a lot of the--
like, when I showed you
the Indian village
data, those are the ones
we obtained by surveys.
And when you ask people for who
their friends are and so forth,
you get biases.
And you get measurement error.
You can't remember all your
friend-- you don't name
all the people and so forth.
When you actually look at other
kinds of footprints, especially
electronic footprints, you
get a different picture
of what's going on.
You don't necessarily see
all of the communication.
But it's hard for
people to forget what's
actually going on online.
And so, mixing these
two things together,
you actually get
different pictures
of how people are communicating.
And so I think the richness of
the data and the understanding
that it actually matters,
both in terms of immobility,
and equality, polarization,
and these kinds of issues,
mean that it's becoming--
it's an area of study that's
exploding, especially
for an economist.
It's happening in
labor economics.
development economics,
where people are trying to
figure out how to help people.
And then it's happening
in computer science.
And now there's more
and more realization
that the algorithms matter.
And thinking of an
algorithm not just
for how it's going to
affect a certain person
but how it's going to affect
a group is a different issue.
And so I think it's a
really wonderful time
to be thinking about this.
AUDIENCE: You were talking
about the rent vouchers study.
And you were saying that there
were three different groups.
There was the control.
Everyone got vouchers.
And then they got
vouchers if they moved.
You were talking about better
outcomes for the people who
moved and got vouchers.
Were those better outcomes
with respect to the control
or with respect
to the people who
got vouchers but didn't move?
And also, how did the people
who got vouchers but didn't move
do with respect to the control?
MATTHEW O. JACKSON: Right--
very good question.
So the comparison I
gave for the $300,000
was between the group that
got vouchers and moved
and then the control group.
And then when you look
within the group that
got vouchers but
didn't have to move,
the people who
actually chose to move
ended up looking like the
group that had to move.
And the people who
didn't move looked
slightly better than the
control group but not much.
So I think, for
an eight-year-old,
it will be more on the
order of like $20,000 as
opposed to $300,000.
So it was a small effect for
the people who got the vouchers
but didn't move.
And it depended.
Some of those groups
actually-- they moved in,
and it made a huge
difference for them.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MATTHEW O. JACKSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Another
question that's
kind of related to
what I was asking
before is how the practice
of economics has changed.
With the change
of technologies, I
don't imagine people were doing
network science and economics
30 years ago or something.
And also, what developments
in other fields
have been adopted to
success in economics?
I recognize some of these
things from statistical physics,
like looking at the degree
distribution, following a power
law, looking like this.
But I'm just
wondering if there is
much of an impact
from other fields
of basic science in
economics and how
it's changed for people?
MATTHEW O. JACKSON: Oh,
great question-- yeah,
so I think of it as--
classic economics thought about
markets in an anonymous way.
So you had people who processed
information, made choices,
weighed costs and benefits.
And a lot of the basic
economics was driven by that.
And I think of it as there
had been two influences that
have a chance to make a big
difference in understanding
a lot of these things.
One is social
structure and networks.
And the other, which brings
in from a different angle,
is what's known as
behavioral economics,
which is getting a lot
of play these days,
where you look at psychological
biases that people have--
overconfidence, or
procrastination,
other kinds of things--
and then try and understand how
that plays into decision making
and how that systematically
biases things.
So you can think about it as--
people were thinking of
fully rational people--
was the classic setting,
where not only were people
able to process all
their information,
but they had all the
information that was out there.
And this gives you
more of a feeling for--
look, people are constrained
by their opportunities.
They're constrained by
their information sets.
And they also have
behavioral biases.
For instance, in our
studies, when I talked
about what's known as
correlation neglect--
the fact that I get seven
friends who tell me something,
and I treat that is seven
independent observations.
It turns out that
they're all correlated.
They all heard it
from the same person.
That's something which is both
psychological and influenced
by the network.
And it's something
you can measure.
So if you were a
good Bayesian and you
understood how these networks
worked, you could undo that.
And you could say, OK, well,
there's actually a chance
that I'm hearing
this indirectly.
And just in my own
thinking, I think
I am very different
in the way I act now
because of studying networks.
So one is, when people
tell me something,
I ask them where
they heard that from.
Where did the
information come from?
And then I also try to
reach out across groups.
So I go to sociology
conferences.
I go to computer
science conferences.
I go to statistical
physics conferences
to try and find new
ideas and information
that I wouldn't be getting
just from economists.
And I think, the more
social sciences can do that,
the better off we'll be.
AUDIENCE: It seems like a lot
of the interesting observations
are generated by this idea
that there are naturally
clusters within the graph here.
So I was wondering if you
have good, formalized ways
of thinking about this?
I've seen ideas like the
normalized cut and whatnot--
but are very hard
to actually compute.
And I was wondering if you
had a good, formalized way
of thinking about clusters
and whether that's
the terms in which you
think about these things?
MATTHEW O. JACKSON: Right.
So there's an area
of network science
which is called
community detection.
And the idea is, as
you're mentioning,
you put down a graph.
And then you try
and find the cuts.
So here, it's not too hard
to see where the cut is.
It's right in the middle.
But in these more
complicated areas, how much
do I dissect a network?
How do I divide
it up into groups?
And I actually have a paper
I just wrote with a student
at Stanford.
And what we do is say, well--
and a lot of it works just
off of graph structure.
So you can look at what's known
as the spectrum of the graph
or other kinds of
things, and then
use those to try and
split the graph up.
There's a lot of
different ways to do it.
But what we did,
instead, was say, well,
if we're trying to do an
economic application with it,
then we want to ask, how would
people behave on this graph?
And let's build the communities
out of the behaviors
that they would induce.
So instead, you actually
say-- for instance,
let's suppose I have a high
school, and most of the kids
are going to act like the
majority of their friends.
How does that split up a graph?
And which groups will end
up acting like each other
consistently?
But none of this turns
out to be easy to compute.
So all of it, in
large graphs, has
to be done by some kind of--
these are all NP-Complete
or NP-Hard problems.
And so you have no choice but to
somehow use an algorithm that's
going to do an approximation.
But in a lot of
graphs, there's ways
to do it that I think gives
you sensible outcomes.
And they can help.
We're doing work
actually in India now,
where we're trying to get
increase in vaccination uptake.
So we're going into
villages, and we're
trying to reach people.
And we're trying to figure
out how to reach them.
And part of that involves
figuring out this structure
and then figuring out
how to target people
inside different groups, and
make sure that they're all
hearing about the programs.
AUDIENCE: It's just a
follow-up on that last comment.
I was curious what
heuristics or tests
you could do to
probe a population
to determine those clusters
without having the graph?
MATTHEW O. JACKSON: Yeah.
So that's a really tricky thing.
Here I've been showing you
graphs where we actually
have all the information.
And one study we
did-- so it turns out,
there's two things that
are true about people
and what their knowledge of
the graph around them is.
First of all, suppose I ask
you to name your friends.
Well, that's
something you can do.
But now if I ask you to name
the other people in this Google
cluster that are
friends with each other,
it turns out people are
slightly better than coin flips
at doing that but not great.
So actually knowing who else
is really friends with whom
and who's talking to
whom is not so easy.
And so it's very difficult
to actually ask people
to reconstruct the graph.
But it turns out that people
are very good at naming
who's central in the graph--
and central not just in
terms of popular but central
in terms of actually Google,
PageRank, and BackRub,
and other notions of--
you're popular.
You're not just popular,
but you're actually
well-connected to other
well-connected people who
can be influential.
And if you ask people, who
are the influential people,
you can actually get
very good answers.
And building off of
that, you're able to do
some statistical
reconstruction of a graph.
You can't reconstruct
the graph perfectly.
But you can get some
ideas of at least
who the key individuals
are and which groups
don't connect with each other.
So there's techniques
of doing that.
And I'd be happy to share
references with you.
But it's just a growing area.
It's starting to grow
right now and study.
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering,
in the example you showed before
of the graph of social
connections in the village
in India where they have
these clique-like things
in the graph--
so are you able
to identify things
that we might expect,
like either the leader
of those cliques or an
ambassador between cliques
reasonably reliably--
or things like that?
MATTHEW O. JACKSON:
So two things--
one, when you're trying
to identify the people who
turned out to be central-- so
we were partnering with a bank
in terms of trying to get the
microfinance information out.
And their algorithm was
to try and locate people
that they thought were central.
And the way they were doing
that was looking for people that
were teachers, self-help
group leaders, shopkeepers,
people they thought interacted
with a lot of people.
It turns out that,
in many villages,
those weren't central people.
And so identifying
central people--
part of the technique
we're using now
is really to go in, and ask,
and then snowball sample.
So we ask somebody
for somebody central.
Then we ask those people.
They tend to be even better
at naming central people.
And then you can quickly
triangulate on them.
In terms of identifying the
clusters and who the people are
that go across them, there
are two extreme groups
that are people who
are big connectors.
So one type is a type who
is actually an outcast.
So in some cases,
you'll find a widow.
In Indian villages,
being a widow
without actually being part
of a family is really tough.
And you'll find some of them
falling between the cracks
and then reaching
out across groups.
And then you also
find some people
who are the major political
figures or connectors
in the villages,
depending on the politics.
It depends on which
village you're looking at.
But some of them actually
reach across the aisle.
And those people-- there's a
bunch of studies in science now
that are looking
at teams of people
doing research and finding that
the people who are actually
those connectors tend
to often have the most
creative and innovative work.
And so there's
actually rewards to it.
But they come from
both sides of the--
people who are doing
really well and people
who are doing really poorly.
And it depends on
the context, I think,
as to who those connectors are.
In the book I
actually spend time
talking about the
Cosimo de Medici
and how he engineered the rise
of the Medici in Florence.
And he was a person--
it's amazing.
When you look at
that graph, he looks
pretty much like a star graph.
He was really connecting
a lot of other people
who weren't connected.
And that was part of the
key to his political clout.
And they rose, even though they
weren't the wealthiest or most
politically powerful family.
But that network position
was really instrumental.
Thanks a lot for having me.